une mortalité plus élevée que celle des
autres pays scandinaves
malgré cette différence l'heure n'est
pas à l'inquiétude du côté de l'exécutif
suédois la stratégie reste la même que
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
pas de confinement instaurer le
gouvernement préfère compter sur le bon
sens des citoyens
la suède n'a jamais fermer ses écoles
primaires et ses collèges les bars et
les restaurants sont toujours restés
ouverts
seule mesure appliquer l'interdiction
des rassemblements de plus de 50
personnes et des visites dans les
maisons de retraite
des initiatives qui semble insuffisante
des responsables sanitaires du pays
nourrissent quelques regrets tout en
émettant des doutes sur la méthode de
comptabilisation des morts nous avons
plus de 4000 personnes mortes à cause du
coc vite 19
c'est très regrettable en suède à
quiconque ait diagnostiqué du coc vite
19 et meurent dans les 30 jours suivant
est qualifié comme étant un cas de kovy
19 quelle que soit la cause réelle de la
mort et nous savons que dans beaucoup
d'autres pays on utilise d'autres modes
de comptage face à ce bilan
stockholm tente de se défendre les
autorités assurent que 90% des décès
concernent les personnes âgées de plus
de 70 ans
le gouvernement reste persuadé que sa
stratégie portera ses fruits sur le long
terme et swedish pas t'aider espelho la
stratégie suédoise est fondée sur une
approche à long terme avec des mesures
qui peuvent être maintenus dans le temps
c'est un mythe que la vie continue
normalement en suède s'il n'y a pas de
confinement complet de la suède
mais de nombreuses parties de la société
suédoise ont fermé mais il est bien trop
tôt pour mesurer le résultat final en
prenant un instantané en plein milieu de
la course
ce n'est pas un sprint c'est un marathon
la suède est l'un des seuls pays
d'europe occidentale à ne pas avoir
instauré de mesures de confinement
et si le pays semble actuellement payé
le prix fort de son modèle
l'heure n'est pas au changement de cap